allier aswak je suis serrurier métallier
je travaille dans une entreprise
alors mon rêve c'est de devenir acteur
faire un film sur des années 60
je m'appelle philippe j'ai 18 ans je
suis étudiant mes copains m'appelle le
gui mon rêve c'est de devenir danseur je
m'appelle pascal mes copains m'appelle
perfecto je suis encadreurs et je n'ai
pas de rêves
j'ai plutôt des cauchemars je m'appelle
eric j'ai 19 ans mes copains me surnomme
dany semail tensionnelle je suis le
frère de pascal je suis d'origine
majorque qui est aussi mon rêve c'est
devenir chanteur alors ouais mon phare
gagne 4000 francs par mois
on verse à notre paye et puis après mes
parents nous redonne pour sortir la
balle à voyager dans la moitié pour
ressortir
bon je travaille touche 4 me je donne
tout mon salaire à mes parents et puis
ils m'ont versé à moitié pour sortir les
week-ends alors au niveau des sorties
mais parle d'un à 350 francs puis
c'est tout l'avenir pour nos verra bien
où l'horreur ouais voilà ça pour
l'instant on a la musique les sorties
entre copains
[Musique]
y a rien rien a besoin a besoin c'est
vraiment mort il n'y a même pas de
cinéma il ya même pas de gare
il n'y a rien du tout a besoin pour ça
qu'on sort le samedi soir sur paris soit
soit les meufs à descendre à paris voir
chez elles en train de dormir tu vas en
train de regarder dallas en plus le fait
d'être avec mes copains je trouve ça
super s'il y avait pas si y'avait pas le
week end
ben ça on pourrait pas on pourrait pas
passer la semaine de travail parce que
nous on n'a qu'un but c'est bien
s'éclater
le week end 1 go
toute la semaine je vais chez philips et
pascal et et on parle on parle des
galères convainc taper ou bien de ce
qu'on va faire
[Musique]
à
ce que j'aimais dans les années 60 c'est
surtout la danse parce que c'était
naturel beaucoup plus naturelle que
maintenant maintenant on cherche
beaucoup plus à faire de petits chichi
tandis que aux années 60 c'était vécu
ouais c'était pure c'était mieux
on avait le temps de se promener dans sa
belle cadillac rose on apprécier la
nature les jolies filles la vie et vous
voulez pour vous accompagne
on peut les accompagner
elle tombait donc la mort le poteau
plus est bonne le plus
j'ai vu qu'il
vagit sur les championnats des mieux
c
[Musique]
moi je n'ai vu que la danse est non
ouais il à la danse tu vois c'est stella
étape s'affiche comme un bel et bien oui
plus ou moins ce que j'aime dans cette
affiche du mois ces cesu comme très
stylé mais on va prendre un teaser de
cette rencontre
je
le milan
tous les marines
quel est votre préféré
je suis pareil a les bonnes pistes et
voies
[Musique]
pourquoi tu brûles au bénéfice des
bureaux mais ça s'était passé mais
j'assume et je sais que tu as vu
commenté taille et le retourneur art est
vachement des mines
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils m'ont
[Musique]
on y est
et comme ça
non non on va pas le décrire tout ce que
tu te rends toi
l'austérité
là je vais pas dire
on a rencontré des amis fantastique là
bas mais faut dire qu'aujourd'hui nous
manque un être très cher les partis là
bas en allemagne quoi faire son service
militaire pour un an à l'arrivée il va
nous manquer prendre un an pour depuis
qu'il est parti à l'armée je suis
angoissé et je sais que après quand il
va revenir de l'armée on va faire
quelque chose ensemble parce que ça fait
longtemps que l'on qu'on parle de de
l'avenir ensemble de ce qu'on pourrait
faire
on avait pensé prendre un appartement
ensemble
pascal je les ai rencontrés il ya un an
et demi à la cité au début on se parlait
pas on se connaissait pas et puis un
jour un beau jour on est sortis tous
ensemble tous les mecs de la cité on est
sortis ensemble puis j'ai vu utile dans
son coin
bon ben moi c'est pareil je parle pas
tellement dense et on s'est rencontrés
on a discuté ensemble puis j'ai retrouvé
en vie beaucoup de choses que moi j'ai
mes mais on a eu pas mal de problèmes
tous les deux on a les mêmes goûts ce
soit pour la musique même même pour les
filles c'est vraiment le l'amitié quoi
entre nous
tu l'avais jose numéro france je crois
que c'est son jardin
m
numéro il n'existe pas assez plu car au
témoin eut donc j'amène amina
on va donner
blue
m
[Musique]